I think I'm a pretty good judge of character and I love sharing tips and tricks with people which genuinely help them to run their clinical practices more efficiently. This episode is supported by WriteUp and they're a brand I've been using in my own clinical practice for over six years. I really do genuinely rate them and use the Write Up platform for each and every clinic session I book or conduct. That's why I'm so happy to be working with them. In case you don't know already, Write Up isn't all in one practice. management platform built in the UK for UK clinicians. So that's your diary, your client records, your notes, your invoicing, your secure messaging, all in one place, all GDPR compliant,
我认为自己看人很准，我喜欢与人分享那些能真正帮助他们更高效地经营临床诊所的技巧和窍门。本期节目由 WriteUp 提供支持，这是一个我在自己的临床实践中已经使用了超过六年的品牌。我确实非常认可他们，并且在我预约或进行的每一次临床会诊中都会使用 WriteUp 平台。这就是为什么我很高兴能与他们合作。如果你还不知道，WriteUp 是一个在英国为英国临床医生打造的一体化诊所管理平台。它涵盖了你的日程安排、客户记录、笔记、发票、安全通讯，所有功能都在同一个地方，并且完全符合 GDPR 标准。
all designed around the way we actually practice. Also, news just in, they've recently launched an AI scribe that drafts your session notes for you and a tap to pay app that turns your smartphone into a card reader. Both are the kind of small changes that quietly give you, hours back every week. But don't worry if you don't want to use all of those features, you don't have to either. If you've been meaning to sort your admin out or you're stuck wrestling with a system that wasn't built for you, take a look at writeup.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P dot com. And when you use my code, Marianne 30, you can access a free 30-day trial with 30% off for six months for up to six users.
所有功能都是围绕我们实际的执业方式设计的。另外，最新消息是，他们最近推出了一个人工智能记录员，可以为你起草会诊笔记，还有一个“点击支付”应用程序，可以将你的智能手机变成读卡器。这两者都是那种能让你每周悄悄节省数小时的小改变。但别担心，如果你不想使用所有这些功能，你也不必使用。如果你一直想整理你的行政工作，或者正被一个不是为你而建的系统所困扰，不妨看看 writeup.com。也就是 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P 点 com。当你使用我的代码 Marianne 30 时，你可以获得 30 天的免费试用，并享受六个月内 30% 的折扣，最多可供六名用户使用。
What's not to like. Now on with the show. Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Thank you so much for being here. The main podcast episode this week is all about extinction learning. And it really got me thinking about kind of reassurance and, you know, how we can sometimes be our own worst enemy. And it often crops up with clients, especially in conditions such as OCD, where someone has got someone else in their life that they've kind of woven into their way of coping so that they are almost undermining themselves on a often multiple times a day basis and seeking that reassurance externally. So this might crop up with OCD so if someone is particularly conscious about
有什么理由不喜欢呢？现在开始节目。嗨，欢迎来到《内在工作》(Inner Work)。我是 Marianne Trent 博士。非常感谢你的收听。本周播客的主要内容是关于消退学习。这让我开始思考关于“寻求保证”的问题，你知道，我们有时如何成为自己最大的敌人。这种情况经常出现在客户身上，特别是在强迫症 (OCD) 等疾病中，当某人的生活中有一个人被他们编织进自己的应对方式中时，他们往往会每天多次地自我削弱，并向外部寻求那种保证。这种情况可能会出现在强迫症中，比如如果某人特别在意
wanting to be fluff free. So their jumper or their jacket might have, they might worry that it's got fluff on it. So yeah, they might have checked themselves and their own top and kind of deemed it to be fluff free. And then of course it's tricky to check your own back. So they might use a mirror and think that it's fluff free, but then, you know, they can't trust themselves. They start to doubt themselves. And, you know, that fear, that good and important reason is maintained. And so in order to bring their whole system down again to feel calmer, they will ask someone to check them. And of course, if you are a partner, of someone who has a condition that's causing them great distress,
想要保持“无绒毛”状态。所以他们可能会担心自己的毛衣或夹克上有绒毛。是的，他们可能已经检查过自己和自己的上衣，认为它是没有绒毛的。当然，检查自己的后背很困难。所以他们可能会用镜子，认为它是没有绒毛的，但随后，你知道，他们无法信任自己。他们开始怀疑自己。而且，你知道，那种恐惧，那种“充分且重要的理由”依然存在。因此，为了让他们的整个系统再次平静下来，他们会要求别人检查他们。当然，如果你是一个患有这种导致极大痛苦疾病的人的伴侣，
then absolutely it makes sense that you think you're helping. When an actual fact, when we begin to unpack and treat an OCD, we're often having to ask people's friends and family to almost come in and be a co-therapist. And whilst we're never wanting to plunge anyone into distress by cutting them off cold turkey. Because this person is consenting to treatment, we are often then saying,
那么你认为自己在提供帮助是完全合理的。但事实上，当我们开始剖析和治疗强迫症时，我们经常不得不要求患者的朋友和家人几乎要参与进来，成为共同治疗师。虽然我们从不想通过突然切断这种支持来让任何人陷入痛苦，但因为此人同意接受治疗，我们通常会说，
you know, is it okay that your loved one will maybe cap the amount of reassurance that you can seek on any given day? So before we begin, we might ask them to do a baseline looking at how many incidents of reassurance there are. And then over time, we'd want to bring that down. So part of the treatment might be
你知道，你的爱人是否可以限制你在任何一天可以寻求保证的次数？所以在我们开始之前，我们可能会要求他们做一个基线调查，看看每天有多少次寻求保证的情况。然后随着时间的推移，我们希望将其减少。所以治疗的一部分可能是
we have to begin to tolerate, you know, what that's bringing up for us. So if you're watching this and you're like, it's only fluff, you know, it could be anything. It could be, you know, fear of bacteria on your hands. It could be anything. But for that person who might have that fear of fluff, it might be that, you know, they were singled out in the past for being scruffy or not well put together enough. or maybe they had a cat who was at school and it would be all over their black trousers and people would humiliate them.
我们必须开始忍受，你知道，这给我们带来的感受。所以如果你正在看这个节目，并且觉得“这只是绒毛而已”，你知道，这可能是任何事情。可能是，你知道，对手上细菌的恐惧。这可能是任何事情。但对于那个可能有“绒毛恐惧”的人来说，可能是因为，你知道，他们过去因为邋遢或不够整洁而被单独挑出来批评。或者也许他们在学校时有一只猫，猫毛会沾满他们的黑裤子，人们会羞辱他们。
So there will be a good and important reason why this matters. And sometimes it can be seemingly unrelated. You know, there might not have been a directly transferable trauma that we can make sense of, but that's just, you know, the thing that helped them feel more in control. So it's that idea of reassurance for fear, really,
所以，这件事情之所以重要，一定有一个充分且重要的理由。有时它看起来似乎毫无关联。你知道，可能没有一个我们可以理解的直接相关的创伤，但这只是，你知道，帮助他们感到更有掌控感的事情。所以这就是关于恐惧的“寻求保证”的概念，真的，
that we need to be able to reassure ourselves. Now, as humans, we are all going to need a little bit of help in regulating ourselves from time to time. Even myself sometimes, I'm like, oh, I just need a hug, or I just need to go and sit by myself. One of my really favourite things to do is to make myself a hotel chocolate chocolate with real milk.
我们需要能够自我保证。现在，作为人类，我们时不时都需要一点帮助来调节自己。即使是我自己，有时也会想，哦，我只是需要一个拥抱，或者我只是需要一个人坐一会儿。我最喜欢做的事情之一就是给自己做一杯 Hotel Chocolat 的热巧克力，用真正的牛奶冲泡。
So I managed to get a little bit of a coogeant, on and I got a box of I think 10 hotel chocolate sachets and ginger hot chocolate. It was delicious. So they gave me one free that got me hooked. But if I'm ever like, oh, I just fancy like a little bit of zen and kind of decompression, then I will make one of those ginger hot chocolates. It just takes like a couple of minutes to heat up the milk, even that ritual of doing that and then whisking in, whisking in that sachet of chocolate, ginger, and it's just a really nice thing. So we shouldn't always soothe ourselves with food. Absolutely we shouldn't, but for me, that really just helps me. In a moment where I might
所以我设法弄到了一点点，我买了一盒大概 10 包的 Hotel Chocolat 姜味热巧克力。味道太棒了。他们给了我一包免费的，让我上瘾了。但如果我什么时候想，哦，我只是想要一点禅意和放松，那么我就会冲一杯那种姜味热巧克力。加热牛奶只需要几分钟，甚至那个仪式感，然后搅拌那一包巧克力和姜粉，这真是一件非常美好的事情。所以我们不应该总是用食物来安慰自己。绝对不应该，但对我来说，这确实很有帮助。在某个时刻，我可能
have, you know, a spare half an hour, I might even be working. So yesterday I had one when I was working at my kitchen island just to just to support me and nourish me. But, you know, the reassurance that we have to be able to apply to ourselves to soothe ourselves. might be different for all of us. So it might be just noticing that I'm having the thought that I need to check myself for fluff. And then we begin to take a breath and to begin with all we're going to do
有，你知道，半小时的空闲时间，我甚至可能还在工作。所以昨天我在厨房岛台工作时喝了一杯，只是为了支持和滋养自己。但是，你知道，我们必须能够对自己施加的、用来安抚自己的那种保证，对我们每个人来说可能都是不同的。所以可能只是注意到我产生了“我需要检查自己身上是否有绒毛”的想法。然后我们开始深呼吸，起初我们要做的只是
is just notice that thought and delay that by a couple of breaths. And then once we're comfortably managing to delay that for a little bit of time, then we've got that balance of power shifted. and then we can begin to delay it or have a different response or, you know, choose our course of action. And over time, that actually does extinguish. It actually does mean that we don't need to use that as a strategy all the time in going forward. Now, what I will say about OCD,
注意到那个想法，并将其推迟几次呼吸的时间。一旦我们能够舒适地将其推迟一段时间，我们就改变了力量的平衡。然后我们就可以开始推迟它，或者做出不同的反应，或者，你知道，选择我们的行动方案。随着时间的推移，这实际上确实会消退。这确实意味着我们在未来不需要一直把这当作一种策略。现在，关于强迫症，我想说的是，
similarly to what I was saying with Martin in the episode, is that this doesn't always, you know, know we were discussing it doesn't always stay flat. And one bit that I was going to add in and I forgot to is kind of thinking about that idea of if you're treating a peanut allergy and then you get it to a stage where someone can tolerate peanuts, that actually you still then have to be able to have regular peanuts in order to keep that at bay. So complete avoidance is not always the way.
和我在那一集中与 Martin 讨论的类似，这并不总是，你知道，我们讨论过它并不总是保持平稳。我本来想补充一点但我忘了，就是思考一下这个想法：如果你正在治疗花生过敏，然后你把它治疗到某人可以忍受花生的阶段，实际上你仍然需要定期接触花生才能保持这种状态。所以完全回避并不总是解决之道。
I would love your thoughts on this. How does reassurance show up for you? How have you learned to reassure and soothe yourself over time? I would love to know. If you've got any ideas for inner work topics you'd like me to explore, please do just let me know. Thank you again for being a member of inner work. And I'll be back along with our next episode very soon.
我很想听听你的想法。寻求保证在你的生活中是如何表现的？随着时间的推移，你是如何学会自我保证和安抚自己的？我很想知道。如果你对我想探讨的“内在工作”话题有任何建议，请务必告诉我。再次感谢你成为“内在工作”的一员。我很快会带着下一期节目回来。
Take care. I think I'm a pretty good judge of character and I love sharing tips and tricks with people, which genuinely help them to run their clinical practices more efficient. this episode is supported by write-up and they're a brand i've been using in my own clinical practice for over six years i really do genuinely rate them and use the write-up platform for each and every clinic session i book or conduct that's why i'm so happy to be working with them in case you don't know already write-up is an all-in-one practice management platform built in the uk for
保重。我认为自己看人很准，我喜欢与人分享那些能真正帮助他们更高效地经营临床诊所的技巧和窍门。本期节目由 WriteUp 提供支持，这是一个我在自己的临床实践中已经使用了超过六年的品牌。我确实非常认可他们，并且在我预约或进行的每一次临床会诊中都会使用 WriteUp 平台。这就是为什么我很高兴能与他们合作。如果你还不知道，WriteUp 是一个在英国为英国临床医生打造的一体化诊所管理平台，
uk clinicians so that's your diary your client records your notes your invoices your invoices your secure messaging, all in one place, all GDPR compliant, all designed around the way we actually practice. Also, news just in, they've recently launched an AI scribe that drafts your session notes for you and a tap-to-pay app that turns your smartphone into a card reader. Both are the kind of small changes that quietly give you hours back every week. But don't worry if you don't want to use all of those features, you don't have to either. If you've been meaning to sort your admin out or you're stuck wrestling with a system that wasn't built for you, take a look at writeup.com. That's W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P dot com.
涵盖了你的日程安排、客户记录、笔记、发票、安全通讯，所有功能都在同一个地方，并且完全符合 GDPR 标准，所有功能都是围绕我们实际的执业方式设计的。另外，最新消息是，他们最近推出了一个人工智能记录员，可以为你起草会诊笔记，还有一个“点击支付”应用程序，可以将你的智能手机变成读卡器。这两者都是那种能让你每周悄悄节省数小时的小改变。但别担心，如果你不想使用所有这些功能，你也不必使用。如果你一直想整理你的行政工作，或者正被一个不是为你而建的系统所困扰，不妨看看 writeup.com。也就是 W-R-I-T-E-U-P-P 点 com。
And when you use my code, Marianne 30, you can access a free 30-day trial with 30% off for six months for up to six users. What's not to like? Now on with the show. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你使用我的代码 Marianne 30 时，你可以获得 30 天的免费试用，并享受六个月内 30% 的折扣，最多可供六名用户使用。有什么理由不喜欢呢？现在开始节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。